you don't sound optimistic you sound
pessimistic so
let's just say you are the founder of
bitcoin and you're the monkey or satoshi
nakamoto
if you are do you regret creating
bitcoin
no i regret not managing things properly
um i noticed you've got a a cross around
your neck and
um i used to be a pastor and i've
actually started roman catholic and
moved over to be protestant
because it fit me better and i like
actually being married
but there's a concept of stewardship
so the whole catholic
ideal of stewardship is important
whether you're protestant or catholic or
whatever else
this idea of having long-term investment
ownership and managing everything
knowing your problems being responsible
this is what really built western
culture responsibility knowing that you
are the center of your own problems and
causes
and what i regret is when i left
when i i sort of left everything
happened the way it was i thought i
could work in the background and and
fix things without being involved
but i abdicated not
sort of delegated there's a big
difference and
part of stewardship is taking ownership
of what you you
cause your problems and everything like
that and
that's what i regret i regret not doing
that not
sort of it was a a harder choice
and i should have made it back then so
what if you're saying
uh um vitalik is public and he's the
leader of ethereum but why were you not
public from day one
i thought things would sort themselves
out i didn't
i mean there was a church of satoshi for
a while
there was a whole lot of other i mean i
did not foresee any of this
um the whole idea of bitcoin in the
protocol is that it doesn't change
none of this we get to keep doing soft
forks or hard forks or anything
the whole concept of set in stone is we
have a protocol
that grows and miners don't
vote as everyone says miners uh don't
choose what the protocol is think about
that for a moment
that is a horrible scenario that is
might
makes right those with the most money
the most power get to choose what
happens in our monetary system
that's not democratic that's not fair do
you really want to see
some large russian company or large
chinese company
dictating world financial policy
that's what these people are arguing
that criminals
can dictate financial policy that can't
be changed
even by government or law enforcement
really think about that for a moment we
get two large miners each with 30
and they have joint control as an
oligarchy
and they can dictate to the rest of the
world that child pornography is good
uh mr antonopoulos writer of mastering
shitcoin
uh came up with this oh well it's not my
place to
tell people that child porn's bad
i mean if people want to do that they
should make their own decisions
wrong i don't care about this
for curly and postmodern ideal
i still believe that we have sort of
an overarching idea of morality
this pluralist system
hegelian uh horrible world of
everyone having a right to whatever they
believe
no matter how low and and despicable it
is is wrong
i don't really care there is a morality
that is native to humanity
and doing the wrong things will never be
acceptable
and allowing a small cadre of
potentially criminals who are money
launderers and want to take
money and do all these things that i've
already mentioned
and get away with it because they have
more hash power
that is asinine